Dragon Balls mouth flaps let's talk
about them I love going back and
watching Dragon Ball Z in the original
4x3 aspect ratio and seeing the bits
where FUNimation added these lines but
failed to account for the fact that the
show might not always be cropped to 16x9
like they did so you end up with Clips
like this where the characters are
saying something but they sure as hell
aren't talking
I can never forgive you for what you've
done
you'd be surprised just how many of
these there are in the show it just goes
to show you kids that Zoom cropping old
shows is evil and the influence of the
Devil Himself FUNimation please save
three Hail Marys to absolve thyself of
this thank you in advance